tonight I'm Brian Ross investigates
American farmers were promised help as a
trade war with China hurt them badly so
we will ensure that our farmers get the
relief they need and very very quickly
but a company run by these two Brazilian
brothers both with criminal records back
home got some 60 million dollars plus of
the money meant for American farmers I
believe that taxpayers need to know how
their money is being expended plus he
was once the top prosecutor going after
the Mafia known as America's mayor now
Rudolph Giuliani is under criminal
investigation by the US Attorney's
Office in New York that he once ran the
whistleblower falsely alleges that I was
operating on my own well I wasn't
operating on my own and our shouted as
the sex abuse scandal at USA Swimming
whitens with a new trial underway this
week the reporter who first broke the
story even as USA Swimming officials and
some of his own readers said there was
no story the newspaper is responsibility
to its readers to sometimes tell them
what they don't want to hear from the
law and crime Network studios in New
York City's Herald Square this is Brian
Ross investigates
good evening and welcome tonight the
story of sixty-two million dollars in US
taxpayers money that was meant to help
American farmers that went instead to a
company owned by two Brazilian brothers
with a criminal past for bribery and
corruption in their home country two US
senators are now asking for a federal
investigation to the brothers and their
company called jbs which even though you
may never have heard of it is now a
major player in American agriculture
owner of some very recognizable brands
[Music]
from its highly produced corporate
promotional videos the JPS company
appears to be a great success built on
hard work and a commitment to corporate
responsibility started decades ago by a
small-time butcher in Brazil it has now
grown into a multi-billion dollar
worldwide beef poultry and pork producer
the largest in the world saying it
provides the world with quality food and
it has now bought up some of America's
best-known brands swift Smithfield and
pilgrims pride but what the company's
videos don't mention is the
scandal-plagued background big news in
Brazil of the two brothers who run the
company George Lee and Wesley Batista
sons of the founder connected to a
massive bribery scheme in Brazil that
allegedly helped them get the money to
buy up the American company Brazilian TV
showing hidden camera footage of the
brothers supposedly making backroom
deals
Joao Maxwell is the executive director
of a trade group that represents
American farmers and ranchers
Organization for competitive markets
there was a lot of illicit behavior
bribing of eighteen hundred politicians
in order to bolster alone through the
Brazilian government so they could enter
the US markets and they have continually
been in a cupped organization
demonstrating corrupt practices from top
to bottom they also were caught bribing
inspectors to allow rotten meat to be
sprayed down with very
chemicals in order to market those back
into the u.s. now in Washington a
bipartisan move for a full federal
investigation of the two brothers and
the company's acquisition of US food
companies in a letter to the secretary
of the Treasury Republican Senator Marco
Rubio a Democratic Senator Robert
Menendez say we are troubled that jbs si
used the ill-gotten financing to acquire
American companies and the Senators also
questioned the group's business
relationship with the Maduro regime in
Venezuela asking for a review of the
company quote to assess the implications
for security and safety of America's
food supply unquote questions about the
company came into a sharper focus when
it was revealed the company had received
tens of millions of dollars in US
taxpayer money that President Trump said
was meant to help American farmers hit
hard by the trade war with China so we
will ensure that our farmers get the
relief they need and very very quickly
it's a good time to be a farmer we're
going to make sure that but when some
sixty million dollars went to the
company it made headlines and provoked
outrage over the brothers they are
criminals living in Brazil who own
massive agricultural companies in the
United States we're looking at 62
million-plus that is going to vary to
very corrupt brothers who have admitted
manipulating the markets who have
admitted that they have bribed federal
food inspectors and government officials
in a statement to Brian Ross
investigates the company said it has
quote fully cooperated with all relevant
authorities in a transparent manner
regarding past events unquote and it
says it is an important American
employer providing more than 60,000 jobs
and partnering with more than 11,000
farmers ranchers and poultry producers
but its critics say that doesn't change
the facts of its illicit behavior so
you've seen this is a corrupt company
and these are the fruits of a poison
tree really these are the fruits of a
poison tree that's exactly right right
and no one should
able to profit from ill-gotten gain out
in the United States you may get away
with that in Brazil or in other
countries but you should not get away
with that in the United States farmers
and ranchers are being harmed consumers
are being deceived
and it's all been brought about because
of the illegal activity that was
conducted in Brazil we applaud senator
Rubio's for his courage to stand up
against the largest meat company in the
world and call for an investigation a
company spokesperson told us that the
two brothers under the terms of their
plea deal with the Brazilian government
have relinquished their executive roles
at the company and now have no
involvement in the running of the
business but the spokesperson did not
address our questions about whether the
money used to buy up the American
companies was a result of the bribery
scheme as the two senators allege next
after a break Rudolph Giuliani the man
who was once the fearless prosecutor
going after the Mafia and wrongdoers on
Wall Street now under investigation by
the US Attorney's Office in New York
that he used to run
we turn now to rudolf giuliani the
former fearless prosecutor dynamic new
york city mayor now president fronts
lawyer and news that he is under federal
criminal investigation by the US
Attorney's Office here in New York that
he once ran and where he made his name
that catapulted him to his political
career which even included a brief run
for president this week in Washington
more testimony from former and current
State Department officials about
Giuliani's role trying to dig up dirt in
Ukraine and former Vice President Biden
and the Sun hunter and his role working
on behalf of at least three different
individuals under criminal investigation
with allegations now that Giuliani tried
to get the Trump administration to go
easy on them it's quite a dramatic fall
from grace for the former prosecutor the
man who led New York City in those dark
days after 9/11 airplane struck the two
large towers of the World Trade Center
we spoke to the
was an attack on the Pentagon we asked
that the airspace around the city of New
York be sealed by military aircraft
two people tonight should say a prayer
for the people that we've lost and be
and be grateful that we're all here and
tomorrow you know tomorrow New York is
gonna be here and we're gonna rebuild
and we're gonna be stronger than we were
before
and joining us now to better understand
what is happening was real of Giuliani
two seasoned lawyers John Moscow a
former prosecutor in the Manhattan
district attorney's office and trial
lawyer Catherine Smith John let me start
with you what's going on with Giuliani
this is his last hurrah I don't know
what's going on with him I watched what
the reports are I see that he is taking
positions that are inconsistent with
what many of us feel the law to be and I
know that he is dynamic and aggressive
and very much over the top which may be
a good thing if you're on the right side
of the wall but can be very troublesome
if you're not Catherine Smith as I asked
you the role of a lawyer he's
president's lawyer he's also
representing individuals seeking help
from the president for them is that a
conflict absolutely absolutely I think
that there's inherent problems with the
way he's dealing with this that not only
create conflicts I was an attorney but
he's digging himself in deeper with his
own legal problems it's very troubling
as you know he said he doesn't need a
lawyer because he's done nothing wrong
on this thing as lawyers what do you say
to that
he's an error small town in Indiana yeah
okay I think there's a saying only a
fool as a lawyer for himself or
something similar like that
yeah well I was a President Lincoln's
lion right yeah well let me play for you
one more Mr Giuliani's more confusing
answers about all of this when he
appeared on Chris Cuomo news program on
CNN where he first denied and then
admitted his role in asking Ukrainians
to investigate the former vice president
never ending anything about hunter Biden
you never asked anything about Jovi only
thing I asked about Joe Biden is to get
to the bottom of how it was that would
Senko who was appointed right dismissed
the case against until you did ask
Ukraine to look into Joe Biden of course
I did you just said you didn't
no I didn't ask him to look in the job
by now yes it wasn't the allegations
that related to my client which
tangentially involved Joe Biden in a
massive bribery spooty not unlike what
he did in China Rudy you explained to me
how the kid got 1.5 billion dollars I
have no patience but just be careful
about what you say I asked you to him
Harry Raina look at Joe Biden you said
no value went on to say that you did
John Moscow you know Giuliani you were
serving in the Robert Morgenthau office
when he was the mayor here's a man who
was articulate had control of the facts
it was very powerful here he looks like
he's losing it look I first heard of
Rudy when Ford was president and he was
working with that levy and a styler in
the Department of Justice he then became
US Attorney in the Southern District and
he was going gangbusters against people
he perceived to be doing wrong he did
quite well against what the organized
crime groups did less well against the
brokers in Wall Street where his conduct
was over-the-top but one had the feeling
that he was motivated by an interest in
doing the right thing that seems to have
gone he seems to be using the same
techniques without any inquiry into
whether the facts are true or whether
what he is doing is correct or right I
don't know for example how he can be
working to represent a money dealer who
whose freedom was important to air to
gun and giving him advice to the people
in the Oval Office about the same
subject it seems to me that that's over
the top he can't be doing both right
you're you're Donald Trump is a person
the president representing the
presidency is a person and the fact is
that Donald Trump is both but he has
different legal interests and rudy is
doing his best to get them
fused because he is representing the
person Donald Trump therefore he can
cause the removal of ambassadors
changing a policy and so on that's just
plain wrong
he isn't hidden supposed to be on that
bail field Catherine Smith is is that
clear you think are the legal ethics
rules so clear on this I do I do and I
also think there's this other step of
how he's conducting himself in seemingly
Cavalier manner and it that's what I
find to be troubling it seems so
apparent to me that there's this
conflict and also then just I mean
essentially calling himself out as being
inconsistent in such a public forum is
odd a question from our control room
from executive producer Rhonda Schwartz
Rhonda what's your question well how
much trouble could Rudy Giuliani
actually be facing it seems like he is
just trying to pull out every stop to
defend his client the president but is
he putting himself in big peril here he
is defending his client Donald Trump and
Donald Trump happens to be president but
the actions that he takes his counsel
for Donald Trump he is seeking to say
he's acting for the president but he's
acting for a human being of course he
could be in trouble first of all he has
foreign agent Registration Act problems
or he may
let's help understand what that means if
he is getting paid by foreign actors to
influence American policy and he is
going on TV or he is going into the
cabinet meetings to influence policy and
it is not disclosed that he is being
paid by another nation or someone
outside the country that is a problem
that may be unlawful I don't know that
he is I let me be clear I haven't looked
at any books of accounts I don't know
but just when the question is asked
could he be in trouble yes clearly he
could be in trouble very serious trouble
and going back to the case involving the
Turkish money dealer that was a Southern
District case
they were very very much involved with
that apparently he signed on as one of
the defense lawyers and there was some
great ambiguity at the time as to what
it was he was doing as a defense lawyer
then it turns out that there was a long
delay in bringing an indictment against
a Turkish bank got filed I believe
yesterday that it looks to me as though
the people in the Southern District who
examined the evidence examined the law
and sought to go forward or perhaps
unhappy with the fact that they have
been impeded by a former prosecutor who
was acting unlawfully getting their
attention under those circumstances was
unwise and trying to stomp on them is it
seriously unwise you have to be right on
the facts or on the law or both and if
they are you're in trouble because he's
basically declaring war on the work
they're doing right well Catherine Smith
essentially what John is saying is don't
miss with a Southern District because
certainly when he ran and when he was
the US Attorney here he wouldn't have
tolerated that that's a very fair
takeaway you don't mess with the
Southern District and you know that
these are very serious allegations and
we don't know what the evidence is going
to bear out but it can run the gamut
from something to you know nothing to
ethical violations to violations of very
severe federal crimes so I think we have
to tune in and see what's yet to come
and the fact that he is a lawyer for
Donald Trump for president Trump does
that allow him great latitude in acting
this way I mean there's some freedom
that we get as attorneys to really
advocate and represent our clients the
best that we can but at the same time
you're representing a person you're
representing also the institution of the
presidency and there's lots of things to
think of behind that you don't get carte
blanche just to say whatever you want
there are ethical requirements you have
to abide by and there's a there's legal
requirements I just disagree that you're
representing the institution if you were
representing Donald Trump that's who you
are representing
and when you were simultaneously
representing Donald Trump and a prime
target of a criminal investigation in
the Southern District you're
representing them both and talking about
the second one's case in the office of
the first one that's it yes I mean I
have not sat down with the statute books
but you're talking about a whole lot
without going far it's a conspiracy to
obstruct justice as well as fara and so
on this is just not it appears to be
something that is most untoward for
someone who's been in his position and
finally a quick question for you John
we've got 30 seconds your former office
the District Attorney's Office here is
beginning to look at President Trump for
a possible involvement is that likely to
happen after it wouldn't happen while he
was president oh you say so I don't
uh-huh judge Marrero dealt with a motion
to quash the subpoena and the second
half of the opinion he went through the
three memos not cases memos written by
the Department of Justice saying that
their chief executive could not be
prosecuted and he pointed out that they
are inconsistent with the American
Constitution
all right Constitution provides for
immunity it does but only for
congressmen under certain circumstances
not for the president under any
circumstance Meath thank you both for
joining us very interesting up next our
shoutout for the reporter who took on a
popular sports organization leading the
way to what has become yet another
shameful sex abuse scandal
as we've been reporting all year there's
a growing sex abuse scandal and yet
another US Olympic sport USA Swimming a
major trial began this week in
California over our lawsuit in which top
officials including its President Tim
Vinci are being accused of a cover-up
which they deny the trial has led to
national attention with articles now in
the New York Times of The Wall Street
Journal but our shout outs that is for
an encore for the reporter who has been
on the story for years doggedly pursuing
the scandal of sexual abuse at USA
Swimming even as the organization and
many of his newspapers own readers said
there was no scandal
Orange County's kind of epicenter of
American swimming this so this was
really our backyard Scott Reed calls
himself a sports investigative reporter
and over the years we've done a lot of
investigative work on sexual abuse in
USA Gymnastics so this kind of blended
into swimming and he quickly realized
USA Swimming had a lot to hide it wasn't
easy it's a very closed network it's a
good old boys network there's a couple
handful of people that kind of run the
sport really powerful coaches and and if
you want to move up in the sport you
know you don't want to cross but we took
the time to listen to survivors young
women who had been abused but who felt
that USA Swimming was covering up what
happened you you asked these survivors
about what happened to him and you're
really the first person to really give
him give them an honest listen and that
was huge I think that was a big part of
our reporting but read stories did not
go over well with USA Swimming and local
readers who were part of the swimming
community lot of push yeah a lot of
pushback you know nasty emails nasty
calls reads most recent story involved
allegations brought against swim coach
Sean Hutchinson he was a World
Championship team coach in 2009 he was
an Olympic team he's on the B team
coaching staffs and he ran this
high-profile Olympic prospect training
group in Fort in California and there
was allegations that Hutchison was
physically involved with a swimmer he
judged by name Arianna Cooper's who was
the world champion a world record holder
and 200 I am during that deck
he stole many things from me including
my swimming career my college experience
friendships my virginity and ultimately
my Olympic dream USA Swimming
investigated it eventually cleared him
of any wrongdoing but documents Reid
obtained told a much different story
what these documents show is that the
person that was hired to investigate
this matter a woman who was a former 20
was a 27 year veteran of the FBI was
told not to interview certain people
without a louder interview certain
people and so what we found was a
deposition and some other documents from
this investigator that proved that this
that the final investigation was this
was just totally incorrect one more
example of the power and importance of
investigative journalism and staying on
the story dictator you have to do you
have to do what's best for the reader
what's best for people you write about
you know the newspaper has a
responsibility to its readers to
sometimes tell them what they don't want
to hear so another shutout tonight for
Scott Reed and his editors at the Orange
County Register helping to lead the way
in exposing years of sexual abuse at USA
Swimming telling readers as he said
things they don't want to hear but need
to hear that's our program for tonight
thanks for joining us we'll see you back
here next week